R would equal a plus s divided by s minus a fantastic algebra skills for giving
that one correct. If you stumble a bit then let's see how we do this, there was a
factoring part to this so that might have been tricky first we multiply both
sides by the LCD r, r minus 1 we distribute the s to get sr minus s is equal to
ar plus a we also have to distribute the a here Now, I'm at this point. And this
is where I need to think back for what I'm solving for. I'm solving for r. So
let's get these r terms on 1 side of our equation. And these other variable
terms here. So we'll have sr minus ar minus s equals a. We get this from
subtracting ar from both sides of our equation. If we add s to both sides. We'll
have the r terms on one side of the equation. And now we want to factor. We take
r out from each of these terms, and then divide each side of this equation by s
minus a. This gives us our final answer. And remember that these two equations
are actually the same. A plus s in the numerator is the same as s plus a.